Writing Japanese.
It's hard.
I know what you're thinking.
Dot.
Josh.
It's Japan.
When they go in,
they go all in,
but it's worse than you think.
It's ridiculously,
ridiculously hard.
Growing up,
I was a language not looking at me making this video,
guess I still am.
Through the years I spent time learning this script and these scripts and these
ones as some time learning this and even more with,
all right,
you get it.
And then I went for Japanese.
See in the u s there's this fluid that goes around.
It's called Japan affilia catch it and you're off reading Manga,
watching anime and eating the kind of Sushi with the fish.
That's all in the top.
Like I was committed though.
I had it for the library and straight to the Japanese books.
This was back when the new library was being built,
so they were holding books hostage in this dingy place with no AC.
The books are all shuffled around down on these low shelves.
You know the ones that are like below your knee level on the ground.
So I do my Ninja band and I scanned the area for resources.
Fluffy book about Japanese is for everybody.
Pass easy Japanese in five seconds a day pass cartoon cat.
Yay.
By the way,
you'll learn some Japanese,
I promise,
double pass.
But then there it was the biggest,
the heaviest,
the densest textbook in the entire section.
Modern Japanese book,
one grammar lessons.
It called my name,
it said the Shul.
So I rush home,
I bust open the book and it hits me with syllables.
My first thoughts are while the optimist in me comes out and says,
oh,
these look so fun and Japanesey,
but guess what?
The pessimist in me said,
that's like 76 more symbols than I want to memorize.
You know,
the pessimists inside me as an owner who is that fast counter,
the optimist one out and for good reason,
it was actually less of a hassle than it looked like at first.
Just 46 characters in total on account of some of the syllables turned out to be
duplicative with two little voicing slashies added to their heads even better.
I was told,
this is technically all I needed to know to write every Japanese sound.
That's all the syllables the language has thanks to Japanese being all neat and
orderly in the way it lays out syllables.
And that's great until I find out that the friendlies syllables are lies.
Like when the t plus East syllable is actually ci,
and then the t plus you syllable is sue or when this,
this,
and this actually sound like that,
that end that the more I read,
the more Japanese was saying,
but wait,
there's more,
more compounds,
syllables,
more double consonants,
more historical syllables.
They were hiding from me and just forgot to mention Asteris mark all over the
place.
But Hey,
historical spelling and complicated work arounds.
I come from English baby and that's how we write.
Plus I just did a whole rant on Tibetans so I can handle some clunky syllables
besides compared to a Japanese syllables east to be written.
It's all super regular.
So that's a relief without giving me time to breathe.
They tell me that for each one of these syllables,
I'm actually going to have to learn to characters.
Yes,
Japanese has two syllabi.
Aries.
The one I spent hours sweating over was these are the same syllables written in,
so our Hiragana and Katakana for writing different sounds.
Nope.
The silhouette is don't do anything different than when do I use this one or
that one.
Oh,
just keep in mind that they're used for different syllables in different
contexts.
Japanese is very context sensitive after all smile,
but none of that is what makes Japanese tough.
It's when they introduced yet another mixed in script that things start getting
serious.
I mean seriously serious.
Roll the clocks back to the day Japan learn to write.
They learned it from China and learning to write from Chinaman memorizing
thousands of characters just to read the basics.
Yeah.
Well unlike other places that learn their penmanship skills from that formidable
cultural powerhouse,
that was the middle kingdom.
Japan held on to it's long master list of Chinese characters.
Oh,
they held onto it real tight.
They're called [inaudible] and they're the backbone of Japanese.
Even though syllabary is,
I was learning came from simplified versions of some of these characters.
At first they pass this Kanji stuff off as a third native system.
You know you've got your Hiragana Katakana,
your Kanji,
and instead of different characters for different syllables.
These are just different characters for different words,
you know,
like how you learned to say new vocabulary.
When you're learning other languages with Kanji,
you get to learn to draw your new vocabulary too.
So exciting.
That's what I learned about a dictionary with more than 50,000 characters to
play with.
That's a lot of characters.
I think it was maybe more of a mind game to make me okay with what came next.
Don't worry.
I was told you could do.
All right.
Reading Basic Japanese if you just learned a couple thousand characters.
Oh,
oh,
just a couple of thousand I guess I was supposed to say.
Oh,
50 thousands a lot.
In that case,
2000 should be a walk in the Zen Garden are,
are you not supposed to walk in those comb through the Zen Garden?
Maybe they even downgraded me again,
telling me I can pat myself on that
back for just mastering the basics.
If I made it through the first 1,006 characters,
1,006 yeah,
this was slow.
It was time consuming.
They started me with these systems,
simple
real world examples like trees,
suns and moons and they looked off,
but if you squint your eyes you could see it,
but it was more trickery.
After a couple hundred it started to be really clear that most Kaji aren't
drawings of the words I was learning at all.
No Way.
It took me awhile,
but I figured out what was going on there.
Like playing charades with somebody who has a very specific word in mind but
refuses to give you any good hints and clues you do get are like way out of
date,
like one word.
Something to do with trees.
Okay.
Sounds like or got it.
Nobody,
nobody.
Oh,
I'm sorry.
The answer was table.
See the thing you missed was that or sounds board,
which is an old word for table obviously.
Yeah.
Most Kanji or this kind of strange combination of a sounds like peace with the
something to do with peace except that the sounds like might not sound like the
thing it's supposed to sound like and it's something to do with can have
absolutely nothing logically to do with what the character means.
It's no good waving these complexities aside by saying that,
well,
it's a lot to learn,
but at least you're fundamentally just learning a character for each basic word.
For one,
a single character might mean a bunch of different things.
When it combos with other characters,
it can even mean a bunch of different things on its own.
Even worst for beginners though,
there's more than one way to pronounce almost every single one of these
characters.
Japanese is very context sensitive.
After all,
wink smile and that is the problem with Kanji.
They aren't just [inaudible].
There are a bunch of problems all mixed together.
It's the most bizarrely complicated writing system within a system ever devised
by humankind and next time I'll show you exactly what it was about Kanji that
really pushed me over the edge.
I like having you here spending some time with me thinking about the world's
toughest writing system.
Stick around and subscribe for language.